taking on carjackers with his bare hands
whilst they were armed with weapons
seahad kolasinac fought off
two men after he and teammate mesut ozil
were targeted in north london
in the footage the arsenal fullback
kolasinac can be seen jumping out of a
vehicle
to confront the masked aggressors they
pulled alongside the car on a moped
before chasing them off after the attack
the footballers fled to a nearby
restaurant
two persons on a motorbike they come in
try to attack him
and they ask him straight away give me
your watch
and then when they try to attack him
and he's trying to go inside of the car
and then from other door the attacker
he's trying to go inside of the car as
well
when he when ozil drive the car they
chase them with a motorbike the owner of
the turkish restaurant in north london
where the players visit regularly
described a terrifying 10 or 15 minutes
drive
that mesa ozil had to take whilst being
chased by
two men on a motorcycle as the robbers
attempted to smash the windows
with bricks and stones it's believed his
wife was also with him and his teammates
in the car
we had a phone call from sight and from
miss ozil please call the police
we've been chased and tried to stop them
break them
they damage ozil's car is very bad
because they draw bigger stones and
a bracket and bricks
scotland yards say officers were called
to northwest london shortly before 5 pm
on thursday a spokesperson for the
metropolitan police
said it was reported that suspects on
motorbikes had attempted to rob a man
who was driving a car the driver along
with his passenger
managed to get away unharmed and
traveled to a restaurant in golda's
green
where they were spoken to by officers no
arrests have been made
and officers are still investigating the
incident
it's not the first time premier league
footballers have been targeted by
thieves
in 2016 then west ham striker andy
carroll
was threatened at gunpoint by two men on
motorbikes
as he drove home from training arsenal
football club has confirmed that both
its players were unharmed
and the club say it does not affect the
player's pre-season training
but the two football stars and childhood
friends will undoubtedly be shaken
after this lucky escape insaman rashid
sky news